[Music]
all right we're going to go to atlanta
georgia with christine hey christine how
are you
i'm doing well
thank you yeah what's going on thank you
so much for everything that you guys do
you've been a blessing to me this past
year since i've been listening to the
podcast awesome thanks for saying that
what's going on
yeah
so right now i'm i have to make
financial decision about sucking uh
selling my second property so this is a
property that i bought back in 2007 when
i was first divorced from my assessment
and um i have been renting it for the
past five
years but it's being rented to my sister
so i'm in a predicament i'm completely
debt free i'm following the baby steps i
believe right now i'm on baby steps uh
four five and six
uh except for this step that i still
have on the second home
yeah so what was your reasoning for
selling the second home you said
i don't i don't want to sell it um
that's that's sort of where i'm at
because my sister are you watching it
christine can you speak directly into
the phone it's hard to hear you it
sounds like you might be driving it
sounds like the window's down or
something
okay sorry about that okay there we go
all right where's christine
so basically what's happening is that
the second home is being rented um to my
sister and my sister's not right now in
a financial capacity to be able to
really
um afford a home and she has um you know
kids that are living there as well
so i don't want to sell the home i have
equity in the home it's worth
230 thousand dollars if i was to sell it
today and i owe 86 000 on it and i've
drastically reduced the debt on the home
um
the past three years since i started my
baby step journey i paid it down about
thirty seven thousand dollars cool is
your primary residence paid for
no it is not um uh my primary residence
is about um it's worth about 420
uh but i owe 190 on that okay and that's
all of your debt is the 86 and the 190
on those properties
other than that i have um no debt no i
paid off my credit cards i paid off my
car
um and you know i paid down as much as i
can out of the uh
you know the depth on that second home
in the past three years since i've been
following the baby steps way to go of
course so are you charging your sister
are you charging your sister rent is she
paying rent right i am charging her rent
yes she's able to pay but it's pretty
much yeah she is able to pay that but
it's the equivalent of my mortgage
payment
um it doesn't pay for the hoa dues so
that's something that i have to go ahead
and take on my own you're losing money
on this right now is what you're saying
i'm losing i'm losing money but it's not
a significant amount but then again
you know i'm trying to follow the baby
steps and i'm trying to make a decision
about what to do and whether i should
continue to eat at this cost or not
yeah this sounds like it's going to be a
hard conversation with your sister and
go hey i want this i want to be a
blessing for you and i want to be able
to provide this but here's my financial
situation and i'm losing money right now
as i rent this thing to you well and i
think i think the other thing is it
doesn't have to feel like this extreme
christine like you're kicking your
sister out on the street you could give
her a three month six month heads up and
it sounds like if you're really charging
her rent market rate rent and she can
pay rent then she can pay rent somewhere
else if the right thing for you to do
is to sell your house you can do it in a
way that is honoring to her that gives
her plenty of heads up um that this is
not the only place that she can live and
if you give her a good transition time
you know then then i think it will not
feel so abrupt to you or her but if this
is the right thing to do for you um then
like george said i think this is just a
hard conversation you have to have yeah
you think she'd be open to that
conversation and saying hey i want to
help you through this three-month
six-month transition period help you
find another place that's affordable
that you can make rent on would she be
open to that
i think she would be um i would have to
give her maybe more than six months on
because she's transitioning careers
right now
but yeah
well it all started
go ahead
yes this would definitely set me up to
maybe pay down my uh home mortgage you
know my first round on the house that
i'm living in right now
and um and be able to start investing
and putting more into my 401k because
right now i can only afford eight
percent yeah you're you're gonna get
there
i think it just starts with a
conversation it may go better than you
think and it may actually even be easier
than you think and she may transition
faster than you think
starts with just having a conversation
but i know you can do it thanks for
calling christine